[Musique]
sur l'échelle des malheurs ça ne se
compare en rien à la guerre et à ses
morts mais la fermeture aujourd'hui du
géant suédois dans toute la russie est
un autre coup de barre et il est majeur
ça fait à peine une demi heure que les
employés l'on t'a pris dans cette petite
succursale de saint pétersbourg qu'on
leur a promis trois mois de salaire et
après personne ne le sait au total ses
15000 postes ou pire qui disparaissent
irina une cliente prend la nouvelle avec
le sourire mais elle ravale ses émotions
la fermeture d'ikea est un autre symbole
du malheur économe et qui s'abat sur les
russes qui voit un monde auquel ils
s'étaient habitués leur glisser entre
les gouttes chez hays spot un des
nombreux distributeurs de produits à pau
en russie il ne reste plus que les
démonstrateurs
giran dit qu'il a tout vendu ce qui
avant stocks en deux jours et pour le
double du prix
il sourit parce qu'on vient tout juste
de recevoir les dernières commandes
placées avant capot une des marques les
plus vendues en russie décide de rompre
les liens avec les pistes il devra
s'approvisionner ailleurs peut-être au
kazakhstan
et quoi qu'en disent les autorités le
pays est en train de sombrer dans une
grande grande crise économique
c'est très bien que les jours de sa
boutique de souvenirs déjà éprouvée par
la pandémie et sont comptés mais elle
refuse de sombrer dans la déprime
[Musique]
des filles
sauf qu'à chaque jour qui passe c'est
une porte de plus fils ferme sur la
russie quelques heures après l'annoncé
officielle en après-midi le plus grand
magasin ikea de moscou était pris
d'assaut
mais à saint pétersbourg il y avait un
calme presque troublant dans cette ville
de russie la plus libérale et la plus
ouverte sur l'europe on entend aussi la
résignation là deviennent que pour un
ikea ferme et alors ça sera remplacée
par une version russe d'ici un an tout
ira bien dit ce jeune homme est dans le
contexte tendu actuelle il vaut mieux ne
pas leur demander ce qu'il pense de la
situation en ukraine car en plus de la
censure militaire imposé à tous les
médias
la douma étudie une loi qui menace
désormais d'envoyer toute personne qui
manifeste contre l'intervention
militaire en prison pour des années il
cite amaral dresse coup radio-canada
saint pétersbourg